When Sarah was a kid, the number of movie stars who came to stay at their house was exactly one. And it was kind of a disaster. Robert Redford ended up at their house because he had heard about a book that Sarah's stepfather was writing about Leonard Peltier and the American Indian Movement. It was still just a manuscript, and the stepfather didn't want to send copies of it around. So he told Redford that the only way that Redford could read it is if he would do it at their house in Long Island. Redford agreed. Sarah says, the atmosphere in the house when he arrived was completely different from any other time in her childhood.
萨拉小时候，曾有位电影明星住进她家，且仅此一位。那次经历简直是一场灾难。罗伯特·雷德福之所以会来，是因为他听说萨拉的继父正在写一本关于伦纳德·佩尔蒂埃和美国印第安运动的书。书稿尚未定稿，继父不想外传副本，于是告诉雷德福，若想阅读，只能亲自到他们在长岛的家中看。雷德福答应了。萨拉说，雷德福到来时，家里的气氛与她童年时期的任何时候都截然不同。
I remember mostly my mother consciously trying to be very charming, and being very charming, and talking to him a lot, and asking all sorts of questions, and laughing a lot at what he said, and kind of flitting about the house in a way that I hadn't remembered her doing before.
我记得最清楚的是母亲刻意表现得非常迷人，她确实也很迷人，一直与他交谈，问各种各样的问题，对他所说的话开怀大笑，而且在屋子里走来走去，那是我以前从未见过的样子。
When Robert Redfored told stories, even the simplest story about his trip to the house, her parents nodded and smiled along with an enthusiasm that the stories did not necessarily seem to merit to 11-year-old Sarah.
当罗伯特·雷德福讲故事时，即使是他去往那栋房子的旅程这类最简单的故事，萨拉的父母也会随之点头微笑，表现出一种在11岁的萨拉看来未必值得如此热情的态度。
I was really sullen. And I think I was making a really concerted effort not to be impressed. Now, 20 years later, I think I was jealous that he was suddenly the star of the house, whereas I was used to being the star of the house. I was the youngest kid. And I was the one who amused my parents. And here was this stranger coming in who had usurped my role.
我当时非常郁闷。我想我当时在极力克制自己，不让自己对他产生好感。20年后，我觉得自己当时是嫉妒他突然成了家里的明星，而我习惯了成为家里的中心。我是最小的孩子，也是那个逗乐父母的人。现在却来了一个陌生人抢走了我的角色。
And I remember when he came in, poor guy, the first night, my mother made this special dinner. And we ate in the kitchen. We had this big wooden table. And it was definitely fancier than usual, or one more course than we usually had. Maybe we had an appetizer or something, which we never normally had. And she had put down these place mats that were-- we only brought them out on special occasions. It all looked really festive and nice. And so he sits down, and we start eating. And Robert Redford says, oh, do you always eat like this? This is so nice. And I said, no. And my mother, at the same time, said, yes, we do.
我记得第一天晚上他进来时，可怜的家伙，我母亲准备了这顿特别的晚餐。我们在厨房吃，有一张大木桌。这顿饭肯定比平时更丰盛，或者比我们通常吃的多了道菜。也许我们吃了一些平时从不吃的开胃菜之类的。她还铺上了那种只有在特殊场合才会拿出来的餐垫。一切看起来确实非常喜庆美好。于是他坐下来，我们开始吃饭。罗伯特·雷德福说，噢，你们总是这样吃饭吗？真是太棒了。我说，不。而我母亲同时说，是的，我们总是这样。
It was bad. And then another thing happened where the seats at that table were these benches. So I was sitting on the same bench as Robert Redford. And I started rocking, partly unconsciously, because I always did that, but also just knowing, I'm sure, that it would be highly irritating to whoever is sitting on the bench with you. So there poor Robert Redford was, rocking back and forth, trying to eat his dinner. And my mother said, Sarah, stop, stop rocking, and scolded me in front of Robert Redford.
糟糕透了。然后又发生了一件事，桌子的座位是长凳。所以我坐在和罗伯特·雷德福同一条长凳上。我开始摇晃，部分是无意识的，因为我一直有这个习惯，但也肯定是因为知道这会让同坐一条凳子的人感到非常烦躁。可怜的罗伯特·雷德福就这样，一边前后摇晃，一边试图吃晚餐。我母亲说，萨拉，停下，别摇了，并在罗伯特·雷德福面前训斥了我。
The next day, a friend of Sarah's from down the street asked if she could come over and meet the house guest.
第二天，萨拉街上的一个朋友问能不能过来见见这位房客。
So she comes over. And she reacts the way you are supposed to react. Her eyes are opened wide. And she's just smiling and talking, and saying, I am such a fan, and I love your movies, and can I have your autograph? And he's delighted. Finally, someone is showing the proper protocol. And he's like, sure, yeah, hey. And my mother is standing there smiling, and how sweet. And she says, "Sarah, would you also like his autograph?" And I said, "No." That was the crowning blow.
她过来了，并做出了你应该有的反应。她睁大眼睛，不停地笑着说话，说我是你的超级粉丝，我喜欢你的电影，能给我签个名吗？他很高兴。终于有人表现出了应有的礼节。他说，当然，没问题。我母亲站在一旁微笑着，觉得很甜蜜。她说，萨拉，你也想要他的签名吗？我说，不。那真是致命的一击。
It's like, somehow, if you picture your family as this little solar system, in and of itself, with its own set of normal gravitational fields and all that, suddenly-- I don't even know what-- another star, another planet entered in. And it completely shifted everyone's orbit away from the way it normally is.
这就像，如果你把你的家庭想象成一个太阳系，有着属于自己的正常引力场，突然间——我甚至不知道该怎么说——另一颗恒星，另一个行星闯了进来。它彻底改变了每个人的轨道，不再像往常那样了。
Right. And I couldn't handle it. All my behavior, I think, was aimed at trying to get it back to the way I had wanted it, or the way I was comfortable.
对。我无法接受。我想我的所有行为都是为了试图让一切回到我想要的样子，或者回到我感到舒适的状态。
Because in the old solar system, pretty much, you were the sun. You were at the center.
因为在旧的太阳系里，基本上你就是太阳。你处于中心位置。
Yes, right. And he was so clearly a bigger sun. He was literally a star. He was a star.
是的，没错。而他显然是一颗更大的太阳。他真的是一颗明星。他是个明星。
Well today on our radio program, stories of what happens when an outsider arrives and changes everything, for better and worse. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass.
今天在我们的广播节目中，我们要讲述当一个局外人到来并改变一切时，无论好坏会发生什么故事。这里是芝加哥WBEZ广播电台，是《美国生活》，由国际公共广播电台发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
Our program today in three acts. Act One, Psychic Buddha, Qu'est-ce Que C'est, the story of what happens to an average American family when Mom, who is completely rational and charming and funny, starts to spend every day in direct contact with an ancient Buddhist monk who no one else can see, who last walked the earth hundreds of years ago. Act Two, The Jackson Two, the story of a politician whose life is shattered by two different men, both of whom share his same name. Act Three, Mr. Fun, Jonathan Goldstein and Heather O'Neill tell the true story of what happened when he first arrived in her life, and why her little daughter explained to him that he is the daughter's 19th favorite person in the world, and not likely to rise. Stay with us.
我们今天的节目分三幕。第一幕，通灵佛陀，这是什么，讲述一个普通的美国家庭，当母亲——她本是完全理性、迷人且风趣的——开始每天与一个古老的佛教僧侣直接交流时，会发生什么；没人能看见这位僧侣，他几百年前就离开了人世。第二幕，两个杰克逊，讲述一位政客的生活被两个名字相同的人摧毁的故事。第三幕，快乐先生，乔纳森·戈德斯坦和希瑟·奥尼尔讲述当他第一次出现在她生命中时发生的真实故事，以及为什么她的小女儿向他解释说，他是她心中世界上第19重要的人，而且不太可能排名上升。请继续收听。
Act One, Psychic Buddha, Qu'est-ce Que C'est. A quick note before we start this next story, one of the people in this story, our reporter's mother, is completely deaf. She woke up one morning when she was 29, and her hearing was gone. And so to communicate with her, the family uses sign language and finger spelling. She can read lips if you talk very, very slow. It sounds like this.
第一幕，通灵佛陀，这是什么。在开始下一个故事之前，简单提一下，这个故事中的人物之一，也就是我们记者的母亲，是完全失聪的。她在29岁那年的一天早晨醒来，听力就消失了。所以为了与她沟通，全家人都使用手语和指拼法。如果你说得很慢，她能读懂唇语。听起来像这样。
Can I have $20?
能给我20美元吗？
Can you have 20--
你可以有20——
Bucks.
块钱。
No.
不行。
This is a story where another man shows up in a family, and the other man is an ancient spirit named Aaron. Mom started channeling Aaron years ago. Aaron has been through lifetime after lifetime, going back a couple thousand years. He instructs her in Buddhism and in meditation.
这是一个关于另一个男人出现在一个家庭里的故事，而那个男人是一个叫亚伦的古老灵魂。母亲多年前开始通灵亚伦。亚伦经历了无数次的轮回，可以追溯到几千年前。他指导母亲学习佛教和冥想。
Her son, Davy Rothbart, put together this story on what it has meant to have Aaron around all these years in their family. But also, when he went to interview everybody in the house that he grew up in, in Ann Arbor, Michigan, he realized that they had never sat down as a family and actually discussed whether they thought Aaron was real, whether they actually believed in Aaron. They got a chance to do that, too. Here's Davy.
她的儿子戴维·罗斯巴特整理了这个故事，讲述了这些年来亚伦在他们家意味着什么。但当他回到他在密歇根州安阿伯长大的房子里采访每一个人时，他意识到他们从未坐下来作为一个家庭讨论过他们是否认为亚伦是真实的，是否真的相信亚伦。他们也有机会讨论了。这是戴维带来的。
I was 12 when Aaron showed up. My older brother, Mike, was 15. My little brother, Peter, was seven. I first found out about Aaron by reading through my mom's journals when she wasn't home. What some people call dirty snooping, I call being curious.
亚伦出现时我12岁。我哥哥迈克15岁。我弟弟彼得7岁。我最初是通过在母亲不在家时阅读她的日记发现亚伦的。有些人称之为偷窥，我称之为好奇。
And I was a curious kid. I remember reading about Aaron this, Aaron that, and all these long, incredible conversations my mom and Aaron had had. For a while, I thought Aaron was some dude my mom was sneaking around with. Then one morning, in the dining room, she explained to me and my brothers about Aaron, how he just came to her one day.
我那时是个好奇的孩子。我记得读过关于亚伦这、亚伦那，以及我母亲和亚伦之间那些漫长而不可思议的对话。有一段时间，我以为亚伦是我母亲暗中往来的某个家伙。后来有一天早上，在餐厅里，她向我和兄弟们解释了关于亚伦的事，以及他是如何有一天突然来到她身边的。
She has always meditated every morning. And I guess this one time in winter, while she sitting quietly in the living room, she felt the presence of someone. Then she saw him, a biblical-looking figure with blue eyes and a long white beard. At first, my mom thought she was hallucinating.
她一直有每天早晨冥想的习惯。我想有一次在冬天，当她静静地坐在客厅里时，她感受到了一个人的存在。然后她看到了他，一个有着蓝眼睛和长长白胡子、像圣经人物一样的身影。起初，母亲以为自己产生了幻觉。
She asked the guy who he was. He said his name was Aaron. He has never gone away.
她问那个人是谁。他说他叫亚伦。他再也没有离开过。
I feel his presence there constantly. But it's like sitting in a room with somebody, and you're reading a book, and they're reading a book. And you don't always have to talk to each other. You just feel the other person's presence. And if it's somebody you really love, there's a comfort in that presence.
我时刻感受到他的存在。但这就像和一个正在看书的人坐在同一个房间里，你们各自看各自的书。你们并不总是需要交谈。你只是感受到了对方的存在。如果你深爱那个人，这种存在感会给你带来安慰。
Is he your best friend, kind of?
他算得上是你最好的朋友吗？
It's not that kind of relationship. Yes, he's a friend, a very dear friend. But it's more a revered teacher than a pal.
那种关系不是那样的。是的，他是个朋友，一个非常亲密的朋友。但他更像是一位备受尊敬的老师，而不是好哥们。
Do you and Dad still knock boots?
你和爸爸还在过性生活吗？
Do we still--
我们还在——
Be makin'--
在制造——
Makin'?
制造？
--with the love?
——爱吗？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
What does Aaron do?
亚伦做什么？
What does Aaron do when we make love? I've noticed that he averts his gaze. That's the one time that he's really not around, although if I called on him, he would be. But I don't feel his presence or energy.
我们做爱时亚伦做什么？我注意到他会避开目光。那是他确实不在场的时候，尽管如果我召唤他，他会来的。但我感受不到他的存在或能量。
When Aaron showed up, one of the first things he did was dictate to my mom a piece of 2,500-year-old Buddhist scripture called the Satipatthana Sutta. My mom says she had never heard of it before. Aaron kept teaching her more scriptures, and coached her in meditation and the Buddhist traditions.
亚伦出现时，他做的第一件事就是向母亲口授了一部2500年前的佛教经文，叫《大念处经》。母亲说她以前从未听说过。亚伦继续教她更多经文，并在冥想和佛教传统上指导她。
After a while, a couple of my mom's friends wanted in on the teachings. So she started showing them how to meditate, and began channeling Aaron for them. It was strange. My mom and Aaron became these gurus, and more and more folks started coming by. Every night of the week, we'd have a crowd of New Age types in the kitchen, grazing on vegan cookies and foraging through our herbal teas. My mom and Aaron would lead meditation sessions out in our converted garage.
过了一段时间，母亲的几个朋友也想参与进来。于是她开始教他们如何冥想，并开始为他们通灵亚伦。那很奇怪。母亲和亚伦成了大师，越来越多的人开始造访。每周的每个晚上，厨房里都会挤满新时代类型的人，吃着素食饼干，翻找我们的草药茶。母亲和亚伦会在我们改建的车库里引导冥想课程。
Gently bring your attention to the touch of the breath.
轻轻地将你的注意力带回到呼吸的触感上。
Wherever my mom was, so was Aaron. And if you're wondering what it was like growing up in a house like this, the only way I can describe it is, it felt completely normal. Aaron was just another member of the family.
母亲在哪里，亚伦就在哪里。如果你想知道在这样的家庭里长大是什么感觉，我唯一能描述的就是，它感觉完全正常。亚伦只是家里的另一个成员。
We'd be at breakfast or driving in the car, and my mom would tell us things that Aaron was saying to her. It was like he was an old college friend of hers who we all knew well. He had a weakness for puns and dumb jokes. He was always marveling at new things that hadn't existed in his last lifetime. I remember how intrigued he was one time by the sight of a Ferris wheel at a school carnival.
我们吃早餐或开车时，母亲会告诉我们亚伦对她说的话。就好像他是她的一位我们大家都熟识的老大学朋友。他有个弱点，喜欢双关语和蠢笑话。他总是对上辈子不存在的新事物感到惊奇。我还记得有一次，他在学校嘉年华上看到摩天轮时有多着迷。
When kids from school came over, me and my brothers always explained about our mom and Aaron. We never really felt embarrassed or weird about it. This was Ann Arbor, the Berkeley of the Midwest. Our friends' parents were ex-hippies and liberal professors. Nobody thought channeling was that strange.
学校里的孩子过来时，我和兄弟们总是会解释关于母亲和亚伦的事。我们从不觉得尴尬或奇怪。这里是安阿伯，中西部的伯克利。我们朋友的父母都是前嬉皮士和自由派教授。没人觉得通灵有什么奇怪的。
Not long ago, on a winter weekend, my brother Mike was in town visiting. And we went for a walk to the elementary school playground near the house.
不久前，在一个冬日的周末，我哥哥迈克回来探亲。我们去房子附近的公立小学操场散步。
I wish I could remember exactly the point when I started to believe that it really was channeling, and not just Mom going slightly psycho.
我希望我能确切地记得我是从什么时候开始相信那确实是通灵，而不是母亲有点精神失常的。
You know what I remember? I just remembered. There was that Shirley MacLaine movie on TV, Out on a Limb.
你知道我记得什么吗？我刚才记起来了。电视上播过那部雪莉·麦克雷恩的电影《走出边缘》。
Out on a Limb. I remember that.
《走出边缘》。我记得那部电影。
And it was just the worst sappy, silly stuff ever.
那简直是有史以来最糟糕、最煽情、最愚蠢的东西。
Right, but Mom loved it and wanted us all to watch it.
对，但母亲很喜欢，还想让我们大家都看。
Yeah. She was eating it up. And it was soon after that she met Aaron. And I was like, that's convenient.
是的。她看得津津有味。不久之后她就遇见了亚伦。我当时想，这真是太巧了。
Mike is 30 years old and married now. He lives in Madison, Wisconsin. He's a professional photographer, and he's into the outdoors. Out of me and my brothers, he's probably the most spiritual. When Mike started getting into Aaron and his teachings, I wasn't sure what to make of it.
迈克现在30岁了，已经结婚。他住在威斯康星州的麦迪逊。他是一名专业摄影师，喜欢户外活动。在我们兄弟几个中，他可能是最有灵性的。当迈克开始深入接触亚伦和他的教义时，我不知道该怎么看待这件事。
I just felt like, you and me and Peter used to all make fun of Mom's students and stuff like that.
我只是觉得，以前你和我还有彼得总是会拿母亲的学生开玩笑之类的。
Mostly, you and Peter used to make fun of them.
主要是你和彼得拿他们开玩笑。
OK. Yeah, me and Peter used to make fun of these weird people that come to the house. But sometimes, you would try to be down with me and Peter. And you would try to make fun of them, too. But then you were up there doing all the voodoo stuff along with the rest of them.
好吧。是啊，我和彼得以前总是嘲笑那些来家里的怪人。但有时，你会试图和我和彼得达成一致。你会试图也嘲笑他们。但后来你却和他们其他人一起在上面做那些巫毒的东西。
I did used to feel torn that I did want to be cool, or be accepted by you and Peter. But I was really interested in what they were doing.
我确实曾经感到纠结，因为我想变酷，或者被你和彼得接纳。但我真的对他们所做的事情很感兴趣。
Of everyone in the family, Mike has turned to Aaron the most. In his freshman year of college, Mike basically had a breakdown. What happened was he started dealing with the fact that he'd gotten molested by a neighbor when he was little. The emotional weight of that started tearing him apart. He couldn't function.
在家里所有人中，迈克对亚伦的依赖最多。在大学一年级时，迈克基本上精神崩溃了。发生的事情是他开始面对自己小时候被邻居猥亵的事实。那份情感重担开始摧毁他。他无法正常生活。
At first, I felt like I was sinking, like in a pit. I was sinking further and further, getting depressed, not doing much of anything. And then, I don't know. I just basically-- eventually, it got so bad that I just called Mom and asked for help. And basically, she said, well, I'll put Aaron on the line.
起初，我觉得自己正在下沉，就像掉进了一个深坑。我越陷越深，变得抑郁，什么也做不了。然后，我不知道。我基本上——最终，情况变得太糟糕了，我只好打电话给母亲求助。基本上，她说，好吧，我把亚伦叫过来。
Right. Some dude touched you improperly. And that seems pretty [BLEEP] up. What can Aaron say that would make that better or go away? He can't take it back.
对。某个家伙以不正当的方式碰了你。那看起来真是该死的糟糕。亚伦能说什么让事情好转或消失吗？他无法撤销这件事。
I wish Aaron was more like the punitive type of spirit. And if you said, some dude improperly touched me, he would just put a bolt of lightning, and like, kshhh-kshhh. You know, we read about it in the paper the next day. Then I would be like, yeah.
我真希望亚伦是那种惩罚性的灵魂。如果你说，有个家伙不正当地碰了我，他就会降下一道闪电，轰地一下。你知道，第二天我们就能在报纸上读到相关报道。那我会觉得，没错。
Right. Basically, when I would call, I would explain how I was doing. And Aaron would just really help me to see things from a more universal perspective. Like here I was--
对。基本上，当我打电话时，我会解释我的情况。亚伦真的能帮我从更普遍的角度看待事情。就像当时我——
Like your problems weren't really that big, or like--
就像你的问题其实没那么大，或者像——
More that my problems were temporary.
更像是我的问题是暂时的。
I remember when Mike would call from school to talk to my mom and Aaron. She didn't have a deaf telephone back then, so Mike would talk to me, and I'd translate into sign language for my mom. And I remember there would be long stretches where I would just do the sign for crying, running my finger down my cheek, again and again.
我记得迈克从学校打电话来和母亲与亚伦交谈时。那时候她还没有听障电话，所以迈克跟我说，我就用手语翻译给母亲。我记得有很多次，我只是不停地做着哭泣的手势，把手指一次又一次地划过脸颊。
Over the past 12 years, I've watched my mom and Aaron help literally thousands of people. Folks come to them in so much pain and seem to leave feeling so much calmer. I have always felt really proud of my mom for all the work she's done to help people through their darkest times.
过去12年里，我看着母亲和亚伦帮助了成千上万的人。人们带着巨大的痛苦来到他们身边，离开时似乎感到平静多了。我一直为母亲在帮助人们度过最黑暗时期所做的所有工作感到非常自豪。
In fact, when Aaron first arrived at our house, things in our family were pretty miserable. Both my mom and dad say that when my mom when deaf, it was incredibly difficult for them, and that it began to tear them apart. Here's my dad.
事实上，亚伦刚到我们家时，家里的情况非常悲惨。父母都说，当母亲失聪时，对他们来说极其困难，这开始让他们分崩离析。这是我爸爸。
I think one way to characterize it would be, just to show how tough it was, it was [SCREAMING]
我认为表述它的一种方式是，为了说明它有多艰难，那是[尖叫声]
That's the way I felt every day, just about every minute, like screaming. And I think I did it frequently enough.
这就是我每天、几乎每一分钟的感觉，就像要尖叫一样。我想我经常这么做。
When I first lost my hearing, it was devastating. It was totally cut off. There was no communication at all, just a sense of being totally isolated from the world.
刚失去听力时，那是毁灭性的。我被完全切断了联系。根本没有任何交流，只是一种被世界完全孤立的感觉。
When my mom first went deaf, she didn't read lips or use sign language. She lost her job teaching sculpture at the university. She couldn't communicate with her friends. In fact, a lot of them just disappeared. My dad got frustrated and upset with her when she couldn't understand him. He says he felt like she was taken from him, like his wife was gone. And he didn't handle it well.
母亲刚失聪时，还不会读唇语或使用手语。她失去了在大学教授雕塑的工作。她无法与朋友沟通。事实上，他们中的许多人都消失了。父亲在母亲无法理解他时感到沮丧和难过。他说他感觉母亲被从他身边带走了，就像妻子不在了一样。而他处理得并不好。
It was a big shock. I had never met anybody that was deaf. And I was concerned that maybe she had brought it on herself, because we went through a mall in Detroit one time on a very cold and windy day, and she refused to put on a jacket or a coat or anything. So I figured that it was her fault. And I kept asking myself the question-- it seems strange now, but the question was, why is this happening to me?
那是一个巨大的打击。我从未见过任何失聪的人。我担心也许是她自己造成的，因为有一次在底特律，我们在一个非常寒冷多风的日子经过一家商场，她拒绝穿夹克或大衣之类的东西。所以我认为这是她自己的错。我不断问自己一个问题——现在看起来很奇怪，但那个问题是，为什么这会发生在我身上？
And Dad was totally overwhelmed by it. He couldn't talk to me. I could talk to him, because he could hear me. He couldn't talk back to me. So we had so much anger. And this anger kept me out.
爸爸完全被这件事压垮了。他没法跟我说话。我能跟他说，因为他能听到我说话。但他没法回应我。所以我们之间积累了太多的愤怒。而这种愤怒让我拒之门外。
I would get mad. I would curse at her. I would yell at her. Of course, she couldn't hear me cursing. But then she told me that, yeah, she could tell the expression in my face, that I was saying something vile.
我会生气。我会骂她。我会冲她大喊。当然，她听不到我在咒骂。但后来她告诉我，是的，她能从我的表情看出我在说些难听的话。
It was like this for 15 years. We could never tell when my dad was going to just blow up. A couple of times, my mom packed me and my brothers into the station wagon, ready to leave. My mom says, she was praying for some kind of relief. And then, Aaron it appeared.
这种情况持续了15年。我们永远不知道爸爸什么时候会爆发。有几次，母亲收拾好我和兄弟们的行李放在旅行车里，准备离开。母亲说，她一直在祈求某种解脱。然后，亚伦出现了。
And after that, things began to change. My mom got a focus and purpose in her life. People looked up to her. She wasn't isolated anymore. And Aaron worked with my dad to help him learn how to manage his anger.
那之后，情况开始好转。母亲在生活中找到了重点和目标。人们敬仰她。她不再孤立无援。亚伦与父亲共事，帮助他学习如何管理自己的愤怒。
It has always seemed to me that my little brother, Peter, is the one in my family most skeptical of Aaron's existence. Growing up, me and him would tease our mom for talking to ghosts. We used to mess around and do imitations of Aaron for our friends. Our favorite thing was when salespeople called and asked for Aaron.
在我看来，弟弟彼得似乎是家里对亚伦的存在最怀疑的一个。长大后，我和他总是拿母亲对着鬼魂说话的事开玩笑。我们过去常闹着玩，在朋友面前模仿亚伦。最喜欢的事是推销员打电话来找亚伦时。
Usually, it's for Mr. Aaron Undetermined.
通常，是找亚伦·待定先生。
They ask for--
他们找——
I guess that's-- yeah, they ask, is Mr. Aaron Undetermined there? I have to explain to them that Aaron is not of this world.
我想那是因为——是的，他们问，亚伦·待定先生在吗？我得向他们解释，亚伦不是这个世界的人。
Do you believe in Aaron?
你相信亚伦吗？
In what sense? Do I think that everything Mom says about Aaron is real? I don't pretend to know. I don't think it's important to me. Like, is Aaron really a higher spirit that tells Mom all this stuff? Or is it just some sort of imaginary friend that developed as a psychological tool for helping her figure out her own problems? It's just like, it doesn't seem like something I can really figure out.
在什么意义上？我是否认为母亲关于亚伦所说的一切都是真实的？我不敢断言。我不觉得这对我来说很重要。亚伦真的是告诉母亲这一切的更高层次的灵魂吗？还是这只是某种心理工具，发展出来帮助她理清自己的问题的想象中的朋友？这看起来不像是我能真正弄明白的事情。
I've got to say, I completely understand Peter's agnostic stance. It's tough to start asking the question of whether or not Aaron is real when either answer you get could be pretty unsettling. I mean, say Aaron is real. Then all the stuff he talks about is real, too. It means God exists, and reincarnation, and that there really is this whole vast spirit world that most of us can't see.
我不得不说，我完全理解彼得不可知论的立场。当你得到的任何一个答案都可能令人不安时，去探究亚伦是否真实是很艰难的。我是说，假设亚伦是真实的。那么他所谈论的一切也都是真实的。这意味着上帝存在，轮回存在，而且确实存在一个我们大多数人看不见的广阔灵界。
But all right, say Aaron's not real. If Aaron's not real, either my mom is lying, or she's deluded. I know she wouldn't straight-up lie about this. She clearly believes in him. Which means if Aaron's not real, then she's a crazy person, and that now, she has snookered thousands of followers into believing along.
但好吧，假设亚伦不真实。如果亚伦不真实，那么要么是母亲在撒谎，要么是她被欺骗了。我知道她不会在这件事上直截了当地撒谎。她显然相信他。这意味着如果亚伦不真实，那么她就是一个疯子，而且现在她已经诱骗了成千上万的追随者相信这一切。
I decided I should just go to Aaron directly. I asked my mom if he would take a meeting with me. She was down, and she said Aaron was down. One snowy afternoon, we went for a walk in the woods behind our house and sat down to talk on a big, old fallen tree. I had a list of questions.
我决定直接去找亚伦。我问母亲他是否愿意见我。她同意了，她说亚伦也同意。一个下雪的午后，我们在屋后的树林里散步，坐在一棵巨大的倒下的老树上谈话。我准备了一份问题清单。
Should I ask them one at a time, or should I ask them all?
我是应该一个一个地问，还是把它们全问出来？
Probably ask them one at a time.
最好一个一个问。
OK. First, could I ask Aaron, what other kinds of humans has Aaron been? Start there.
好的。首先，我可以问问亚伦，亚伦曾经是什么样的人类？从这里开始。
Start there.
从这里开始。
My mom leans back slightly and closes her eyes. She perches on the snowy log, breathing deeply and sitting completely still.
母亲微微后仰，闭上眼睛。她蜷坐在雪地里的圆木上，深呼吸，坐着一动不动。
I have lived in every color of body, male, female, arctic climates and tropic, in deserts and wilderness and mountains. And so have you. But you don't remember them. I do.
我经历过各种颜色的身体，男性，女性，北极气候和热带气候，在沙漠、荒野和山脉中。你也一样。但你不记得了。我记得。
Aaron says he last walked the Earth in human form about 500 years ago in Thailand. In that lifetime, he was a Buddhist meditation master, and my mom was one of his prized students. One night, a man attacked Aaron with a spear. And my mom gave her life to protect him. Aaron says he and my mom have been together in many lifetimes as teacher and student. In a couple of lifetimes, he's even been her father.
亚伦说他上一次以人类形态行走于世大约是500年前在泰国。那一世，他是佛教冥想大师，母亲是他最得意的弟子之一。一天晚上，一个人用长矛袭击亚伦。母亲为了保护他献出了生命。亚伦说他和母亲在许多轮回中一直在一起，作为师生。在其中几世里，他甚至当过她的父亲。
I have a question for you, Aaron. Aaron, isn't it possible that my mom invented you, because she felt so alone and isolated with her deafness?
我有个问题问你，亚伦。亚伦，难道不可能是我母亲发明了你，因为她在失聪后感到太孤独和孤立了吗？
I would not phrase it quite that way. First, I can not prove that I'm real, and it's not necessary. Certainly, she could have invented me. In my experience, that's not what happened, because I exist.
我不会那样表达。首先，我无法证明我是真实的，也没必要。当然，她可能发明了我。以我的经验，事实并非如此，因为我存在。
Since it's not something one can prove either way, I tend to simply ask people, whether she invented me or I'm quote, "real," the ideas that I offer come from somewhere. Are they useful to you? Forget me. Are the ideas useful to you, [INAUDIBLE]?
既然这无法证明，我倾向于简单地问人们，无论她是发明了我还是我“真实”存在，我所提供的观点都来自于某个地方。它们对你有用吗？忘了我吧。这些观点对你有用吗？
Baseball--
棒球——
Davy, these are all baseball cards.
戴维，这些都是棒球卡。
Later that afternoon, Mike and I went up into the attic to look for some old pictures and things.
那天下午晚些时候，我和迈克去阁楼找一些旧照片和东西。
Where do you think your-- wait, what's this one?
你觉得你的——等等，这张是什么？
At one point, my mom came up to help. She started telling me about a weekend channeling workshop she gave a few years ago. She said that channeling is not some sacred gift, that even my brother Mike had channeled once.
有一次，母亲上来帮忙。她开始跟我讲她几年前举办的一个周末通灵研讨会。她说通灵并不是什么神圣的天赋，甚至我哥哥迈克也曾经通灵过。
Mike channeled?
迈克通灵过？
Mike channeled--
迈克通灵过——
You don't remember that, Davy? Yeah.
你不记得了吗，戴维？是的。
Is that hereditary? I thought channeling skips a generation.
这是遗传的吗？我还以为通灵隔代遗传呢。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
No, my experience is that anybody can learn how to channel. As I said, it's like playing basketball. Doing it is easy. Doing it well is hard. Davy, Dad was channeling too.
不，我的经验是任何人都可以学习如何通灵。就像我说过的，就像打篮球。做起来很容易。做好很难。戴维，爸爸也曾经通灵过。
Dad was channeling? No.
爸爸通灵过？没有吧。
True. Dad was channeling.
是真的。爸爸通灵过。
You're pulling my-- you're yanking--
你在跟我开玩——你在耍——
We had 20 people here, and about 18 of them ended up channeling by the end of the weekend. Ask Dad. Is Hal down there? Hal, come on around here.
当时有20个人在这里，周末结束时大约18个人都进行了通灵。问问爸爸。哈尔在下面吗？哈尔，过来这儿。
What?
什么？
OK, a word about my dad. He's a real performer, the kind of dad who will improvise Gilbert and Sullivan songs with new lyrics, always willing to entertain.
好的，关于我爸爸的一点说明。他是个真正的表演者，那种会用新歌词即兴演唱吉尔伯特和萨利文歌曲的父亲，总是乐于娱乐他人。
Did I ever channel?
我通灵过吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Yes.
没错。
So you remember channeling?
那你记得通灵的事吗？
Sure, I took the channeling class through your mother.
当然，我参加过你母亲开设的通灵课。
You channeled?
你通灵过？
I channeled, yeah.
我通灵过，是的。
Beautiful, was it?
很精彩，是吧？
Oh yeah. I have a tape of it.
噢，是的。我有录音带。
Who'd you channel?
你通灵的是谁？
You're saying?
你说什么？
I channeled Munga, Munga.
我通灵的是蒙加，蒙加。
Who did he channel?
他通灵的是谁？
I could probably do it again.
我大概能再做一次。
Can you channel Munga right now? I'm asking Dad to channel Munga.
你能现在通灵蒙加吗？我让爸爸通灵蒙加。
My dad stands there on the pull-down attic steps and closes his eyes, while my mom gets an increasingly worried look on her face.
爸爸站在拉下的阁楼楼梯上闭上眼睛，而母亲的表情看起来越来越担忧。
Hal, I would strongly suggest that you not take Davy up on that challenge.
哈尔，我强烈建议你不要接受戴维的挑战。
Not unless you sit down and meditate and get yourself into a stupendous bliss.
除非你坐下来冥想，让自己进入一种极其美妙的极乐状态。
Dad, just don't worry about it. She's crazy. She's channels.
爸爸，别担心。她是疯的。她通灵。
I think I'm feeling his presence.
我想我感觉到他的存在了。
I'm asking for respect for the process.
我要求尊重这个过程。
OK. I can sit down. If I sat down-- I'd have to be more comfortable.
好的。我可以坐下。如果我坐下的话——我得更舒服一点。
I think my mom hoped that that would be the end of it.
我想母亲希望那是事情的终点。
Hey, Big Papa.
嘿，大老爸。
The next morning, I got my dad alone while he was shaving in the bathroom.
第二天早上，趁爸爸在浴室剃须，我把他叫到一边。
How come Mom wouldn't let you channel Munga earlier?
为什么母亲早些时候不让你通灵蒙加？
Here's my feeling about it. I think she felt that it wasn't sincere, but it was real. It was real.
我对此的感受是。我想她觉得那不真诚，但它是真实的。它是真实的。
Could you do Munga now? Can you try? I know sometimes you feel him closer than others, but--
你现在能做蒙加吗？你能试试吗？我知道有时你觉得他比平时更近，但是——
I could do it. I feel his presence. I won't be able to shave. I'd have to stop shaving. But I could do it. I feel him around. I have to close my eyes and concentrate a little bit.
我能做到。我感觉到他的存在。我没法剃须了。我得停止剃须。但我能做到。我感觉他在周围。我得闭上眼睛，专注一点。
Hello. My name is Munga, and I come from India. I'm here now. Now I'm speaking. And--
你好。我的名字是蒙加，我来自印度。我现在就在这儿。我现在在说话。而且——
Not to be disrespectful, and not to focus on Munga's accent, but I just didn't find this as believable as my mom's channeling. Still, though, there's my dad, standing there at the sink in a bright green bathrobe, his glasses on and shaving cream all over his face, channeling. Already, this was turning into one my favorite memories of my dad ever.
并不是要不尊重，也不是要关注蒙加的口音，但我只是觉得这没有母亲的通灵那么可信。不过，我爸爸还是站在水槽边，穿着一件亮绿色的浴袍，戴着眼镜，脸上满是剃须膏，正在通灵。这已经成为了我关于爸爸最喜欢的记忆之一。
Munga, this is Davy. And can I ask you--
蒙加，我是戴维。我能问你——
Davy is number two son, born April 11, 1975. 5 foot 11, 152, I believe, 142. I have these feelings about your physical appearance.
戴维是二儿子，生于1975年4月11日。5英尺11英寸，152磅，我相信，142。我对你的外表有这种感觉。
Munga was like one of those carnival barkers that try and guess your exact height and weight, or you win a giant pencil. Why didn't Aaron ever entertain like this?
蒙加就像那些游乐场里试图猜中你的确切身高体重、让你赢得巨大铅笔的摊贩一样。为什么亚伦从不这样娱乐大家？
I have no more to say. And peace to all human beings on planet Earth, you call it.
我无话可说了。和平属于地球上所有的人类，你们这么称呼它。
I never really realized my dad was so cool with the whole spirit world thing. He was always a gracious host at all the meditation classes and channeling sessions. But sometimes he also seemed to resent how wrapped up in Aaron and her work my mom had become. She was always going out of town to lead meditation retreats and workshops around the country. And I don't think he liked being home alone so much of the time. And sometimes my dad would get annoyed by all the students constantly coming in and out of the house.
我以前从没意识到爸爸对整个灵界的事这么随和。他在所有的冥想课和通灵会议上一直是个热情的东道主。但有时他似乎也对母亲变得如此沉迷于亚伦和她的工作感到不满。她总是出城去全国各地主持冥想静修和研讨会。我想他不喜欢大部分时间独守空房。有时爸爸会因为学生们不断进出家门而感到烦恼。
Honestly, I thought Aaron was just something he tolerated. But listening to him and Munga, I felt moved. Really, what could be a sweeter way for him to show acceptance of my mom's work than for him to channel his own spirit?
老实说，我以为亚伦只是他容忍的一种东西。但听到他和蒙加的对话，我深受感动。真的，对于他来说，展现对母亲工作的接纳，还有什么比他亲自通灵自己的灵魂更甜蜜的方式呢？
Is Aaron just a part of you?
亚伦只是你的一部分吗？
I have no idea. I don't experience him as a part of me.
我不知道。我并不觉得他是我的一部分。
There were still a couple of questions I had left for my mom. I know Aaron has dictated entire books to her, interpretations of ancient Buddhist writings. Scholars who've read them have been impressed. With Aaron's teachings, she's become a widely known and respected meditation teacher. Even the most established Buddhist bigwigs admit that the depth of her knowledge is astounding.
我还有几个问题留给母亲。我知道亚伦已经向她口授了整本书，是对古老佛教著作的诠释。读过这些书的学者们都印象深刻。有了亚伦的教义，她成为了一位广为人知且备受尊敬的冥想导师。即使是最资深的佛教大咖也承认她知识的深度令人惊叹。
But then there's sketchy things, too. Like one time, when Aaron said the thing he missed most about being an actual human being was the taste of cognac. Aaron's last lifetime was supposedly more than 500 years ago. And I checked it out. Cognac was barely invented then. And the only people drinking it were a few dudes in France, not Buddhist monks in Thailand. And then there's the fact that Aaron says he can read minds and see the future, but then refuses to demonstrate these powers.
但也有一些可疑的地方。比如有一次，当亚伦说他作为真正人类时最怀念的是干邑白兰地的味道。亚伦的上一世据称是500多年前。我查了一下。那时候白兰地才刚刚发明出来。当时只有法国的少数几个人在喝，而不是泰国的佛教僧侣。还有就是亚伦说他能读心和预见未来，但却拒绝展示这些力量。
Why won't he just prove himself? It's so easy. I have a number between 1 and 100.
为什么他不直接证明自己？这太容易了。我心里有个1到100之间的数字。
He says he won't play that game.
他说他不玩那个游戏。
So he's not real.
所以他不真实。
That's for you to decide.
那得由你来决定。
Does he know the number? He doesn't have to say it. I just want him to know the number. Does he know it?
他知道那个数字吗？他不一定要说出来。我只想让他知道那个数字。他知道吗？
He says he is averting his eyes. He is choosing not to look at it.
他说他在避开视线。他选择不去看它。
I'm begging him, please, I just want to know. And then, I know it doesn't matter. His teachings are pretty cool. It doesn't matter if he's real or not. But I just want to know. So just look. Aaron, I'm asking you for one second, just look.
我恳求他，求求你，我只是想知道。然后，我知道这无关紧要。他的教义很酷。他是否真实并不重要。但我只是想知道。所以看一眼吧。亚伦，我求你一秒钟，看一眼。
If you want to understand what having Aaron in our lives has really done for my family, here's something that happened while I was home to work on this story. We went out to dinner on Valentine's Day. My dad met us at the restaurant, and when he walked in, he said, Happy Valentine's Day to my mom. But she had just turned away and didn't see him say it. My dad got kind of agitated, as though she was ignoring him by choice. He still hasn't fully gotten over her deafness.
如果你想了解亚伦进入我们的生活对我们家庭到底做了什么，这里有一件事发生在我回家制作这个故事的时候。我们情人节出去吃饭。爸爸在餐厅遇见我们，当他走进来时，他对母亲说情人节快乐。但她正好转过头没看见他这么说。爸爸变得有点激动，好像她在故意忽视他一样。他还没完全克服她失聪的事。
A minute later, he said something else to her, but now he was sore at her, and he didn't use sign language, and barely moved his lips. My mom said, I can't understand you. And my dad, getting more upset, repeated himself even faster, way too fast to lip-read.
一分钟后，他又对她说了些什么，但现在他很恼火，没用手语，嘴唇几乎没动。母亲说，我听不懂你在说什么。而爸爸，变得更加不安，说得更快了，快到根本读不出唇语。
This used to be how it would all start with them. My dad's anger at my mom's deafness would bring out her unhappiness over it. Soon they'd be shouting at each other.
这以前是他们之间所有争吵的开头。爸爸对母亲失聪的愤怒会引发她对此的不满。很快他们就会互相大吼大叫。
But Aaron's influence has changed everything. On Valentine's Day, when my dad started freaking out, my mom just smiled at him and shrugged, like, this is your problem, not mine. Things don't escalate the way they did before Aaron came around. He's helped my mom discover a total sense of calm. Aaron came in peace, and that's what he brought us.
但亚伦的影响改变了一切。情人节那天，当爸爸开始发飙时，母亲只是对他微笑并耸了耸肩，好像在说，这是你的问题，不是我的。事情不再像亚伦出现前那样升级了。他帮助母亲找到了绝对的平静感。亚伦带来了和平，这就是他带给我们的。
Now if Aaron hadn't come along--
如果亚伦没出现——
I think Dad and I would have been divorced. I'm not sure. Maybe not. I'm not sure.
我想爸爸和我会离婚的。我不确定。也许不会。我不确定。
I understand why my mom believes in Aaron. As for me, I think believing in Aaron is a lot like believing in God. I have a hard time having an unswerving faith in something you can't see or prove exists.
我理解为什么母亲相信亚伦。至于我，我认为相信亚伦就像相信上帝。要我对看不见或无法证明存在的东西产生坚定不移的信仰，对我来说很难。
But I do have that kind of faith in my mom. That's why I believe in Aaron. You, you'll have to make your own decision.
但我对母亲有那样的信仰。这就是为什么我相信亚伦。至于你，你必须自己做决定。
Davy Rothbart is the creator of foundmagazine.com. Now here's Davy's dad, using his improvisatory powers.
戴维·罗斯巴特是foundmagazine.com的创始人。现在是戴维的父亲，发挥他的即兴表演能力。
Hey Pete, hurry down. Dad's going to sing.
嘿，皮特，快下来。爸爸要唱歌了。
[SINGING] If you're a God-fearing man, and you're trying to answer all the personal questions that you can, I suggest you call A-A-R-O-N. Aaron is the man that can solve your problems. Do you have any today? It's the way to live in the world today. Can you solve your problems?
[唱歌]如果你是一个敬畏上帝的人，并且你正在尝试回答所有你能回答的私人问题，我建议你呼唤A-A-R-O-N。亚伦是那个能解决你问题的人。你今天有什么问题吗？这就是当今世界的生活方式。你能解决你的问题吗？
If you can't, let me remind you, there's a wonderful spirit in the world. And his sayings are good as gold. Some are modern, and some are pretty old. So my response to you--
如果你不能，让我提醒你，世界上有一种美妙的灵魂。他的言论如黄金般宝贵。有些是现代的，有些相当古老。所以我的回答是——
Coming up, the difficult task of running for Congress against someone with your exact same name. And a seven-year-old explains a few things to a grown-ass man, in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来，与同名者竞争国会议员的艰巨任务。以及一个7岁小孩向一个成年大男人解释一些事情，稍后继续，来自芝加哥公共广播和国际公共广播，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week, of course, we choose some theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, The Other Man, stories in which some outsider arrives on the scene, disturbing the normal orbits of the planets, disrupting how everyone deals with everyone else. We have arrived at the second act of our show, Act Two, The Jackson Two.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周，我们当然会选择一个主题，为您带来关于该主题的各种不同故事。今天的节目，《另一个人》，讲述一些局外人到达现场，扰乱了行星的正常轨道，破坏了每个人与他人相处方式的故事。我们已经进入节目的第二幕，《两个杰克逊》。
Imagine for a second what it would mean to grow up with the name Jesse Jackson if you weren't the Jesse Jackson. With me so far? Now imagine if you grew up with the name Jesse Jackson, and you were Jesse Jackson's son, and you wanted to go into public service of some kind.
想象一下，如果你不是那个杰西·杰克逊，却顶着杰西·杰克逊这个名字长大，那意味着什么。跟上我的思路了吗？现在想象一下，如果你顶着杰西·杰克逊的名字长大，而且你是杰西·杰克逊的儿子，你想从事某种公共服务。
Your dad would forever be the other man in your life. His shadow would always be there, his presence an invisible boulder in any room you walk into. Run for office, there are going to be some people who love you, and some people who dismiss you, because of your dad, whose name you share. OK.
你爸爸永远会是你生命中的另一个人。他的影子将永远存在，他的存在就像你走进任何房间时的一块无形巨石。竞选公职，总会有人因为你分享的名字而爱你，也总会有人因为你爸爸而轻视你。好吧。
So after 34 years of living with the name Jesse L. Jackson, Jr., and seven years of living as Congressman Jesse L. Jackson, Jr., for Illinois's second district, here in Chicago, Jesse L. Jackson was in a meeting with campaign workers, when somebody told him about this strange turn of events.
所以在顶着杰西·L·杰克逊二世这个名字生活了34年，并以伊利诺伊州第二选区杰西·L·杰克逊国会议员的身份生活了7年之后，就在芝加哥，杰西·L·杰克逊正在与竞选工作人员开会，有人告诉他这个奇怪的事件。
And he said, have you heard the news? Have you heard the news? I said, no, what's the news? He said, at 11:59, the last minute of filing for Congress in the second district of Illinois, you now have another Jesse L. Jackson running against you.
他说，你听到消息了吗？你听到消息了吗？我说，没有，什么消息？他说，在11点59分，伊利诺伊州第二选区竞选国会议员截止报名的最后一分钟，你现在有了另一个杰西·L·杰克逊在和你竞争。
I think at first, people were questioning whether there really was such a person.
我想起初，人们在怀疑是否真的有这样一个人存在。
Oh, I didn't realize that, that there was an actual question of if he even existed.
噢，我没意识到这一点，竟然有人质疑他是否存在。
Yes.
是的。
Mike Brown covered all this for the Chicago Sun-Times. He says that the other Jesse L. Jackson turned out to be a retired truck driver who lived in a suburb called Robbins, 68 years old, no previous political experience.
迈克·布朗为《芝加哥太阳时报》报道了这一切。他说那个另一个杰西·L·杰克逊原来是一个退休卡车司机，住在叫罗宾斯的郊区，68岁，没有任何政治经验。
At first, we couldn't even find him. He was ducking everybody. And then they produced him for a little dog and pony show, where he came out in front of the microphones and read a statement that said he really does exist. Indeed, he was a real person. And he was just a regular guy, who clearly had somehow been recruited to get into this race.
起初，我们甚至找不到他。他在躲着所有人。后来他们把他拉出来做了一场小型作秀，他站在麦克风前读了一份声明，说他确实存在。当然，他是一个真人。而且他只是一个普通人，显然不知何故被招募来参加这场竞选。
But recruited by whom? Well, nobody was admitting anything. But for weeks, news reports were featuring gleeful quotes from two local politicians, Robert and William Shaw. They're twin brothers, old-school operators who came up through the rank and file of the black Democratic organization, who reportedly resent the relative ease with which Jesse, Jr., became a congressman.
但被谁招募的？嗯，没人承认任何事。但几周以来，新闻报道中一直充斥着两位当地政客罗伯特·肖和威廉·肖幸灾乐祸的引语。他们是双胞胎兄弟，通过黑人民主党组织内部一路打拼上来的旧式操作员，据报道他们对杰西二世成为国会议员的相对轻松感到不满。
After all, he started at the top. It was his first elected office. They call him a brat and a crybaby. And as soon as this other Jesse L. Jackson appeared on the ballot, they were merrily telling reporters and anyone who would listen that it only seemed fair that Congressman Jackson realized that he wasn't the only one who could run for office on his father's name.
毕竟，他是从顶层开始的。这是他第一个当选的公职。他们称他为顽童和爱哭鬼。而一旦那个另一个杰西·L·杰克逊出现在选票上，他们就兴高采烈地告诉记者和任何愿意倾听的人，杰克逊议员意识到他不是唯一一个能靠父亲名字竞选公职的人，这似乎才公平。
THE only way he got in public office is through his daddy's name. But this other Jackson has had the name long before this young boy had it, the congressman.
他进入公职的唯一方式就是靠他爸爸的名字。但这个另一个杰克逊在那个小男孩、那个议员还没这个名字之前很久，就有了这个名字。
Senator William Shaw talked to me from his office.
威廉·肖参议员在办公室跟我谈话。
You know, I'm so happy, looking back at history, that Andrew Jackson didn't come along in this time. He never would have been the president, if it had been left up to this guy.
你知道，回顾历史，我很高兴安德鲁·杰克逊没有出现在这个时代。如果让这个家伙说了算，他永远也当不成总统。
Wait, wait, Andrew Jackson? Explain what you mean.
等等，等等，安德鲁·杰克逊？解释一下你的意思。
You know Andrew Jackson?
你知道安德鲁·杰克逊吗？
Yeah, of course.
是的，当然。
He was one of the presidents.
他是总统之一。
Right, right, of course. He's on the money.
没错，当然。钱币上有他。
But listening to Congressman Jackson, anybody with the Jackson name, he feels as though they shouldn't run. This guy's out of his mind. He thinks he has a patent on the Jackson name.
但听听杰克逊议员的话，任何叫杰克逊的人，他觉得他们都不应该参选。这家伙疯了。他以为他拥有杰克逊名字的专利。
From the congressman's point of view, this is all pretty much exactly what you do not want people talking about in the newspapers and on television. Again, imagine you have spent your whole life trying to get out from under the shadow of that other Jesse Jackson, your father, and now there is yet another Jesse Jackson. And the main story about your reelection is not what you've accomplished for your district, or what you hope to accomplish, but once again, did you get your job on your daddy's name.
从议员的角度来看，这几乎完全是你不想让人们在报纸和电视上谈论的内容。再想象一下，你花了一辈子试图走出另一个杰西·杰克逊——也就是你父亲——的阴影，现在却又有了另一个杰西·杰克逊。而你连任的主要故事不是你为选区完成了什么，或者你希望完成什么，而是再次变成，你是不是靠你爸爸的名字得到的这份工作。
You know, and for someone who takes the process very seriously, it has been annoying. In the last six years, I have had eight press conferences. Two of them have been on this subject. To give you some idea that I don't run to the media, to show you some difference between me and my father, my dad might have had eight yesterday.
你知道，对于一个非常认真对待这个过程的人来说，这很烦人。在过去六年里，我开了八次新闻发布会。其中两次是关于这个主题的。让你知道我不是那种会去找媒体的人，展示一下我和我父亲的区别，我爸爸昨天可能开了八次。
I'm not anti-press. I'm prepared to do press. But when I do press, I want it to be about issues of concern to my constituents. And so rather than running a race on a third airport in Peotone, or discussing O'Hare expansion, or how to get more jobs, I'm caught in a fight with people who aren't even running for Congress in my race.
我并不反对媒体。我准备好面对媒体。但当我面对媒体时，我希望那是关于我选民关心的议题。所以，与其在皮奥顿的第三机场问题、讨论奥黑尔扩建，或者如何获得更多工作机会的竞选中比赛，我却陷入了与甚至没有参加我选区竞选的人的争斗中。
The people he refers to, of course, are the Shaw brothers. They deny having anything to do with Jesse Jackson of Robbins, the truck driver. But Congressman Jackson started investigating the petition drive that put Jesse Jackson of Robbins onto the ballot. He found that many people who signed the petitions had been told specifically that they were signing for the congressman, who enjoys a 90% approval rating in the district. Further investigation showed that those petitions were notarized by a political ally of the Shaws. The 4,400 signatures were gathered by men who came from a homeless shelter, one of whom has testified that they got the jobs gathering signatures one day when Senator Shaw's chief of staff came by and took them to the Shaws' office at 144th street. In an affidavit, this man said that both William and Robert Shaw were there in the room, and sent them out to get the signatures.
他指的是当然是肖氏兄弟。他们否认与罗宾斯的杰克逊，那个卡车司机有任何关系。但杰克逊议员开始调查让罗宾斯的杰西·杰克逊出现在选票上的请愿行动。他发现许多签署请愿书的人被明确告知他们是在为议员签名，议员在选区享有90%的支持率。进一步调查显示，这些请愿书是由肖氏兄弟的政治盟友公证的。这4400个签名是由来自一个流浪汉收容所的人收集的，其中一人作证说，他们得到收集签名的工作是在某天肖参议员的幕僚长顺路过来把他们带到肖氏在144街的办公室时。在宣誓书中，此人说威廉·肖和罗伯特·肖都在房间里，并派他们出去收集签名。
Not only there and sent them out, but there eating catfish and sent them out. And specifically said, "Go help the congressman. We don't get along with the congressman. We don't care much for the congressman. But we're going to help him get back on the ballot."
不仅仅是在那儿派他们出去，而且是在那儿吃鲶鱼时派他们出去。还明确说，去帮帮那个议员。我们和议员合不来。我们不太喜欢那个议员。但我们要帮他重新进入选票。
Now, the congressman is saying that he's got affidavits from people who went around and got signatures to get this other Jesse Jackson-- the one from Robbins-- onto the ballot. He says he has got affidavits from some of those people, saying that they met, they were organized, in Shaw headquarters. What do you all say to that?
现在，议员说他有来自那些四处奔走收集签名让另一个杰西·杰克逊——那个来自罗宾斯的——进入选票的人的宣誓书。他说他有一些人的宣誓书，说他们是在肖的总部见面、组织起来的。你们对此怎么说？
I don't say anything. You know, anything might have happened. I have hundreds of people in my headquarters coming in and out. We're involved in a campaign here. And to my knowledge, I don't know anything about that. And I think that the congressman, he's drinking some water probably out of DC. We have better water than that in Chicago.
我什么也不说。你知道，任何事都可能发生。我的总部有成百上千的人进进出出。我们在这儿竞选。据我所知，我对此一无所知。而且我认为这位议员，他可能在华盛顿喝了一些水。我们在芝加哥的水比那好。
Wait, wait, and what does the water from DC do to you?
等等，等等，华盛顿的水对你有什么影响？
The water is making him delirious. That's what I think.
那水让他神志不清。我是这么认为的。
For a while, there were not only two Jesse L. Jacksons on the ballot. The Shaw brothers officially supported a candidate in the primary named Yvonne Williams. And at some point, another Williams turned up on the ballot as well, Anthony Williams. And of course, this happens on ballots all over the country.
有一段时间，选票上不仅有两个杰西·L·杰克逊。肖氏兄弟正式支持初选中的一名候选人叫伊冯娜·威廉姆斯。而某个时候，另一个威廉姆斯也出现在选票上，安东尼·威廉姆斯。当然，这种情况在全国各地的选票上都会发生。
If you're running against an Irish politician, you get another Irish name on the ballot. If you're running against a woman, you get another woman. If you're running against Jesse Jackson, you get another Jesse Jackson. Again, William Shaw.
如果你在和一个爱尔兰政客竞争，你就会在选票上找另一个爱尔兰名字。如果你在和一个女人竞争，你就会找另一个女人。如果你在和一个杰西·杰克逊竞争，你就会找另一个杰西·杰克逊。再次，威廉·肖。
Yeah, that has happened many, many times. And people just take it with a grain of salt. It's not such a big deal.
是的，那种事发生过很多很多次。人们只是听听而已。这没什么大不了的。
Yeah, I was wondering if you think we should think it's tragic or just funny.
是啊，我很好奇你觉得我们是该觉得它悲剧还是仅仅觉得好笑。
Well, I don't know. I guess it's funny to everybody but the congressman.
嗯，我不知道。我想这对所有人来说都很好笑，除了那个议员。
Well, it is kind of funny.
嗯，这确实有点好笑。
Again, Congressman Jackson.
再次，杰克逊议员。
But there are political forces in my congressional district that are notorious for election shenanigans, for deceiving voters, and even having the reputation of stealing voters.
但在我的国会选区有一些以选举诡计、欺骗选民、甚至有偷选票名声而臭名昭著的政治力量。
And after deploying seven lawyers, two private eyes, and $150,000 to investigate how Jesse L. Jackson of Robbins got onto the ballot, the congressman is pursuing legal action. And if he can prove that the Shaw brothers intentionally deceived voters, intentionally tried to convince voters that they were signing petitions for the congressman, when in fact they were signing for the other Jesse L. Jackson, then this entire incident will move out of the category of political prank, and into the rather more serious category of political fraud, a criminal offense. The Shaw brothers could end up out of office, or far worse.
在部署了七名律师、两名私家侦探和15万美元调查罗宾斯的杰西·L·杰克逊是如何出现在选票上之后，议员正在采取法律行动。如果他能证明肖氏兄弟蓄意欺骗选民，蓄意试图让选民相信他们是在为议员签署请愿书，而实际上他们是在为另一个杰西·杰克逊签名，那么整个事件将从政治恶作剧的范畴上升到更严重的政治欺诈范畴，这是一种刑事犯罪。肖氏兄弟可能会丢掉公职，甚至更糟。
Rabbit hunting is fun until the rabbit gets the gun. And so what happens when you come up against another big bear in politics, who has the resources and the capability of pursuing it to the nth degree of the law, and starts demanding justice? And I saw the same Eddie Murphy movie that they saw, and I'm determined not to let it happen in our district.
猎兔很有趣，直到兔子拿到了枪。那么当你面对政治上的另一头大熊，拥有资源和能力将法律追究到底，并开始要求正义时，会发生什么？我看过和他们看过的同一部艾迪·墨菲电影，我决心不让这种情况在我们选区发生。
The Eddie Murphy movie being?
那部艾迪·墨菲电影是？
The Distinguished Gentleman. A gentleman who gets elected to Congress by the name of Jefferson Johnson. After the congressman dies-- his name is Jeff Johnson-- he runs for Congress, and he gets elected. He's a felon, by the way.
《滑头绅士》。一个名字叫杰斐逊·约翰逊的绅士当选为国会议员。在国会议员去世后——他叫杰夫·约翰逊——他参加国会竞选，并当选了。顺便说一下，他是个重罪犯。
You think that actually they saw the movie?
你认为他们真的看过那部电影吗？
I'm pretty sure someone saw it. And I think what's also becoming clear is that many people forgot how the movie ended, and that is that some people went to jail.
我很确定有人看过。而且我想越来越明显的是，很多人忘记了电影是怎么结束的，那就是有人进了监狱。
After several weeks on the ballot, Jesse L. Jackson of Robbins dropped out of the race after his wife died. In the March primary, the congressman took 85% of the vote. Hearings, depositions, and testimony continue to wind their way through the courts.
在选票上待了几周后，罗宾斯的杰西·L·杰克逊在妻子去世后退出了竞选。在三月的初选中，议员获得了85%的选票。听证会、证词和作证继续在法庭中进行。
[MUSIC PLAYING - "NUDE AS THE NEWS" BY CAT POWER]
[音乐播放 - 凯特·鲍尔的《NUDE AS THE NEWS》]
Act Three, Mr. Fun. We have this story on what it is like to intrude on a perfectly happy, perfectly idyllic family of two, when one of the two falls in love with you, and the other most definitely does not. Heather O'Neill and Jonathan Goldstein explain what happens.
第三幕，快乐先生。我们有这个故事，讲述当一个人爱上你，而另一个人绝对没有时，闯入一个完全幸福、完全田园诗般的两人家庭是什么感觉。希瑟·奥尼尔和乔纳森·戈德斯坦解释了发生的事。
I was 20 years old when Arizona was born. I thought I could just put her in a little suitcase, and that would be her bed. I figured now that I had given birth, the hard part was over.
亚利桑那出生时我20岁。我以为我可以把她放进一个小手提箱，那就是她的床。我以为既然我生了孩子，最难的部分就结束了。
I moved into a big building over a laundromat, where they didn't ask for any references. People left their apartment doors open and waved to you from their couches when you walked down the hall. The apartment was our own cozy little universe of porcelain dolls, posters of Hong Kong, and tiny, colorful paper umbrellas. It was a universe of two plates, two cups, and two toothbrushes, until I met Johnny.
我搬进了一栋自助洗衣店楼上的大楼，那里不要求任何推荐信。人们在走廊里走过时，会敞开公寓门，从沙发上向你挥手。公寓是我们自己由瓷娃娃、香港海报和微小的彩色纸伞组成的舒适小宇宙。直到我遇到约翰尼之前，那是一个由两个盘子、两个杯子和两把牙刷组成的宇宙。
I was introduced to Heather by some friends over drinks. I was impressed by how fast she drank her beer. And she was impressed by the fact that there was only one arm on my eyeglasses. From the side, you look like a cartoon doctor, she said. She looked like she was from some bygone era, where women worked with their hair tied up in kerchiefs on assembly lines, to help the war effort. By all of this, I mean to say that I was smitten by her.
是朋友们在喝酒时把我介绍给希瑟的。她喝啤酒的速度让我印象深刻。而她对我的眼镜只有一条镜腿的事实感到印象深刻。她说，从侧面看，你看起来像个卡通医生。她看起来像是来自某个早已过去的时代，那个时代女性为了战争努力，头上系着头巾在流水线上工作。我想说的是，我被她迷住了。
I knew that Heather had a little girl. And I also knew that I wasn't very good with children. Ironically, my job at the time was teaching after-school magic classes to kids in elementary schools. I wasn't that great a magician to begin with, and kids made me nervous. My hands were always sweaty, and I was always dropping coins all over the place.
我知道希瑟有个小女孩。我也知道我不擅长和孩子相处。讽刺的是，我当时的工作是在小学里教课后的魔术课。我本身并不是什么厉害的魔术师，而且孩子让我紧张。我的手总是出汗，而且总是把硬币掉得到处都是。
One time, I was really losing the attention of a classroom of sixth graders while teaching them the jumping rubber band. So I told them that if they listened quietly, at the end of the class, I would walk through a wall. Immediately, they all shut up.
有一次，我在教他们跳动橡皮筋时，真的失去了六年级学生课堂的注意力。所以我告诉他们，如果他们安静地听，下课时我会穿墙而过。他们立刻都闭嘴了。
At the end of the class, I took about two full minutes where I just stared at the wall at the back of the classroom. If any of them said a word, I would reprimand them for breaking my concentration and start all over again. Finally, I slowly started walking towards the wall. The way the kids were looking at me, all open-mouthed and expectant, I almost felt like I could actually pull this off.
下课时，我花了大约整整两分钟盯着教室后墙。如果他们中有谁说了一个字，我就斥责他们破坏了我的专注力，然后从头再来。最后，我慢慢开始走向墙壁。孩子们看着我的样子，张大嘴巴，满怀期待，我几乎觉得自己真的能做到。
When I smacked into the wall, I turned to them and said, "You didn't really think I could walk through a wall, did you?" They all looked at the wall, then they looked at me. Then slowly, reluctantly, they all shook their heads no. I hoped I would have better luck with Heather's daughter.
当我撞上墙壁时，我转向他们说，你们真的以为我能穿墙吗？他们都看着墙，然后看着我。然后慢慢地、勉强地，他们都摇了摇头。我希望自己在希瑟的女儿那里会有更好的运气。
Over drinks, I had told Johnny that Arizona had shoved our TV set off the coffee table. And now-- surprise, surprise-- here he was, carefully winding his way up the staircase to our house, with an old RCA in his arms, the old-fashioned antenna still attached and dragging behind him on the floor. When he came in, Arizona was over at the neighbors', a Greek family who liked to give her a good bath every now and then. It was a family event for them, with shish kabobs, and an uncle who played accordion on the closed lid of the toilet.
喝酒时，我告诉约翰尼亚利桑那把我们的电视机从咖啡桌上推了下去。而现在——令人惊讶的是——他正小心翼翼地沿着楼梯爬到我们家，怀里抱着一台旧RCA，旧式天线仍然连着，在他身后的地板上拖着。他进来时，亚利桑那在邻居家，那是一个喜欢偶尔给她好好洗个澡的希腊家庭。这对他们来说是一项家庭活动，有烤肉串，还有一位叔叔在合上的马桶盖上弹奏手风琴。
As me and Johnny sat on the couch, Arizona walked into the apartment, freshly scrubbed, smelling of baby powder and Greek food, with four bows in her hair. Johnny kept clapping his hands together and going on about how she looked just like Shirley Temple. She stopped dead in her tracks and gave me a confused look.
当我和约翰尼坐在沙发上时，亚利桑那走进了公寓，洗得干干净净，带着婴儿爽身粉和希腊食物的味道，头发上扎着四个蝴蝶结。约翰尼不停地鼓掌，一直说她看起来就像秀兰·邓波儿。她停下脚步，困惑地看着我。
Before he left, he asked me if I wanted to come to his house for dinner that weekend, and I said, sure. I called my sister and asked if she would babysit. She begged me not to have another boyfriend. In other words, no babysitting. So I took Arizona along on my date with Johnny.
他离开前，问我那个周末想不想去他家吃晚饭，我说，好的。我打电话给姐姐，问她愿不愿意当保姆。她求我别再交男朋友了。换句话说，没保姆。所以我带亚利桑那去和约翰尼约会。
I stood on my front steps waiting for her to get there. And when I saw her coming down the street, pushing a stroller, I wondered if I had any juice in the house. We sat down at my kitchen table, and I brought out a big pot of curried vegetables and rice. Arizona climbed up on the table, opened the lid, and wrinkled her nose. I picked her up and put her back down in her chair. But as soon as I did, she would get right back up and roll around all over the plate, most of the time while pointing at me with an angry look on her face. She wasn't like Shirley Temple at all. She was like the Muppet Baby Joe Pesci.
我站在前台阶上等她过来。当我看到她推着童车沿着街道走过来时，我想知道家里还有没有果汁。我们坐在厨房桌旁，我端出一大锅咖喱蔬菜和米饭。亚利桑那爬上桌子，打开盖子，皱起鼻子。我抱起她把她放回椅子上。但只要我一放下，她就会马上爬起来，在盘子上滚来滚去，大部分时间还带着愤怒的表情指着我。她一点也不像秀兰·邓波儿。她像个布偶乔·派西。
After dinner, Johnny walked into his living room and saw the word "Arizona" written in pen with a backwards R on his desk. At first, I was sort of delighted. It was the first time she had ever written her name without me coaching her. But I kind of felt for Johnny, whose apartment was all full of neatly arranged furniture and superhero figurines that stayed exactly where they had been placed. Johnny walked around the apartment with his head down and an expression on his face like he was a seven-year-old reviewing times tables in his head.
晚饭后，约翰尼走进客厅，看到桌上用笔写着带有反向R的“亚利桑那”字样。起初，我有点高兴。这是她第一次没经过我的指导写下自己的名字。但我有点为约翰尼感到难过，他的公寓里摆满了井井有条的家具和超级英雄小雕像，它们正好留在被摆放的地方。约翰尼低着头在公寓里走来走去，表情看起来像个正在脑子里复习乘法表的七岁小孩。
He tried to ease into our lives with grace. After the first time he slept over, he got up in the morning, before Arizona woke. He put on his jacket and went outside into the hallway and knocked on the front door, pretending he had just arrived. "We don't want to damage the child's psyche," Johnny said.
他试图优雅地融入我们的生活。第一次在他那儿过夜后，他早上起来，在亚利桑那醒来之前。他穿上夹克，走到走廊外，敲了敲前门，假装他刚到。约翰尼说，我们不想损害孩子的心理。
Arizona's bedroom was closest to the front door, so she got up and let him in. "Hi," he said. "I was just in the neighborhood." He walked in without shoes and his belt undone. He dropped onto the couch and fell back asleep. Arizona looked at him. "Why do you even come by," she said angrily, "if all you're going to do is go to sleep."
亚利桑那的卧室离前门最近，所以她起来让他进来。他说，嗨，我刚好在附近。他光着脚、解开皮带走了进来。他倒在沙发上又睡着了。亚利桑那看着他。她愤怒地说，如果你只是要回来睡觉，你为什么要过来？
Johnny and I had very different ideas about the environment in which one should raise a kid. "The stove needs to be fixed," he complained. "You can't cook meals over a hot plate. Ratso Rizzo cooks meals over a hot plate. And who, in God's name, puts laundry out on the line at midnight?" "Children need discipline. They like it," was a favorite banner of project Goldstein.
我和约翰尼对抚养孩子应该在什么样的环境下有非常不同的想法。他抱怨说，炉子需要修理。你不能在电炉上做饭。拉索·里佐才在电炉上做饭。而且，到底有谁会在午夜把衣服挂在晾衣绳上？项目戈德斯坦最喜欢的一句口号是，孩子需要纪律。他们喜欢纪律。
Heather called all of my domestic tips "bourgeois." "How is cleaning the crisper bourgeois?" I asked. "How in the world is keeping your child from running naked through the halls of the apartment building wearing my boots a symptom of the bourgeoisie?"
希瑟称我所有的家务建议都是“资产阶级”。我问，清理冰箱保鲜盒怎么就成资产阶级了？你到底怎么会觉得阻止你的孩子穿着我的靴子赤身裸体在公寓大楼大厅里跑是资产阶级的症状？
Arizona could tell that Johnny was trying to change things, and everything between them became a battle of wills. She would reach over and squeeze the Indiglo button on his watch. And he would chastise her, telling her that Indiglo was used only in emergency situations, like if you were in a blackout, or stuck in a cave. But as soon as his head was turned, she pushed the button again.
亚利桑那能看出约翰尼试图改变事情，他们之间的一切都成了意志的较量。她会伸手去捏他手表上的夜光按钮。他会训斥她，告诉她夜光功能只在紧急情况下使用，比如你在停电时，或者被困在洞穴里。但只要他一转头，她又按下了那个按钮。
In what I considered a bit of cultural exchange, I had her sit on the couch and listen to the soundtrack from Fiddler on the Roof. Arizona, all of six years old, turned to me in the middle of "If I Was a Rich Man" and said, "That's what you do all day long. You biddy biddy bum." She paused for a moment, and then, just to make sure the point wasn't being lost on me, she added, "That means you're lazy." When the three of us walked down the street, Arizona would say, "My mom's shadow is longer than yours. That means you're short."
在我认为算是文化交流的一次尝试中，我让她坐在沙发上听《屋顶上的提琴手》原声带。年仅六岁的亚利桑那在《如果我是个富人》那首歌唱到一半时转向我，说，那就是你整天做的事。你“比蒂比蒂蹦”。她停了一会儿，然后，为了确保我没漏掉重点，她补充道，那意味着你很懒。当我们三个人走在街上时，亚利桑那会说，我妈妈的影子比你的长。那意味着你很矮。
She was starting to like him less and less. One day, he made her list all the people that she loved most in order. "And who do you love next best?" he would ask, hopefully. "And the next? And the next?" He came in at number 19. He actually ranked below the neighbor's dog, and the plumber who drank two-gallon bottles of Pepsi while he worked, and let Arizona hand him wrenches.
她开始越来越不喜欢他了。有一天，他让她按顺序开列她最爱的人名单。他满怀希望地问，那你下一个最爱的是谁？再下一个？再下一个？他排在第19名。他实际上排在邻居的狗，以及工作时喝两加仑百事可乐、还让亚利桑那帮他递扳手的管道工之后。
Every time I tried to kiss Arizona, she would pull back, insisting that my beard was too scratchy. It got so that I was shaving twice a day. But still, she would wave me off. I would stand in front of the mirror like an obsessive compulsive, desperately scraping the blade across my cheeks, the word "scratchy" ringing in my head like the raven's nevermore.
每次我试图亲吻亚利桑那，她都会退缩，坚持说我的胡子太扎人了。后来我甚至一天剃两次胡子。但她还是会把我挥开。我像个强迫症患者一样站在镜子前，绝望地用刀片刮过脸颊，“扎人”这个词像乌鸦的“永不复还”一样在我脑海中回荡。
One time, we had some friends over at Heather's, and someone started playing the guitar, and Arizona started to dance. It struck me as one of the most beautiful things I had ever seen. Everyone stood around and clapped their hands while Arizona spun around with her arms over her head. Before I knew it, I was walking over and taking her hands to dance with her. I wasn't the type to dance with kids, or to even dance at all, for that matter. But I just couldn't help myself.
有一次，我们在希瑟家有些朋友，有人开始弹吉他，亚利桑那开始跳舞。这让我觉得是我所见过的最美丽的事情之一。大家围在一起鼓掌，亚利桑那举着双手旋转。我还没反应过来，我就走过去牵起她的手和她一起跳舞。我不是那种会和孩子跳舞，或者甚至跳舞的人。但我就是情不自禁。
When I touched her, she whipped her hands away and stopped cold. I retreated back to my seat as the music continued to play. All the while, Arizona stared me down like her prison bitch.
当我碰她时，她猛地抽出手，僵住了。随着音乐继续播放，我退回了座位。一直以来，亚利桑那盯着我，就像她是我的狱霸。
He tried buying her love with really inappropriate gifts, things that he liked that he thought she might learn to like. He bought them matching wallets and a mood ring that wouldn't fit her for at least another five years. He got her a pop-up book of nightmare analysis that included a chapter on giving birth to aliens.
他试图用非常不合适的礼物来买通她的爱，他觉得她可能会学着喜欢的他喜欢的东西。他买了匹配的钱包和一个她至少还要五年才戴得上的心情戒指。他给她买了一本噩梦分析立体书，里面有一章是关于生下外星人的。
In the best of times, she treated him as something that made me happy, and she quietly tolerated him, like the way she sat through a Hitchcock documentary at the museum. But then sometimes, she would just explode. One day at Burger King, he refused to let me bring her hamburger back to the counter for a third time to ask for even more pickles. And she started screaming. She pounded the hamburger with her fists.
在最好的时候，她把他当作让我开心的东西，她静静地忍受着他，就像她在博物馆里看希区柯克纪录片一样。但有时，她会爆发。有一天在汉堡王，他拒绝让我为了多要点酸黄瓜第三次带她的汉堡去柜台。于是她开始尖叫。她用拳头捶打汉堡。
"I can't stand him," she said. "Why did we have to go out with him today? Tell me why." "He's my friend," I said, "and you have to pretend to like him." She had a little friend who would come over and bite his own toes while they watched TV, and I never said a thing. I figured it was the least she could do for me.
她说，我受不了他。我们今天为什么非得和他一起出来？告诉我为什么。我说，他是我的朋友，你得假装喜欢他。她有个小朋友会过来，一边看电视一边咬自己的脚趾，我从来没说什么。我觉得这是她为我能做的最起码的事了。
One day, I was trying to finish my dad's income tax, and Arizona was bored. She was whacking the wind chimes with the broom. She was all out of ideas when Johnny asked her if she wanted to take a walk with him. She sighed and got her jacket. Before they left, he explained that the plan was to walk to a bank to cash his check, and then find a barber that would cut his hair for a reasonable price.
有一天，我试着完成我爸爸的所得税申报，而亚利桑那很无聊。她一直在用扫帚敲击风铃。当约翰尼问她想不想和他一起去散步时，她已经没主意了。她叹了口气，拿上了夹克。他们离开前，他解释说计划是走到银行兑现支票，然后找一家理发店以合理的价格理发。
We were walking along when Arizona came to an abrupt stop, and so I stopped, too. She looked up at me, and in this tone that I had never heard her use before, she said, "This isn't what you do to have a good time." It was like she had summoned up every little bit of maturity she had, and some she didn't even have. And she used her words to let me know something that she felt was really important for me to know, that I just wasn't any fun.
我们走着走着，亚利桑那突然停了下来，所以我也停了下来。她看着我，用一种我从未听她用过的语调说，这不是你为了玩得开心而做的事。就像她召唤出了她拥有的所有那点成熟感，甚至还有一些她根本没有的。她用言语让我知道了一些她觉得非常重要的事情，那就是我一点都不好玩。
And she told it to me in this way that was like, maybe it just wasn't something I knew, and that maybe I just had to be told, and then everything would be OK. Like maybe it could all be that easy. We went back to the apartment and got our bathing suits. Arizona wanted to go to the beach.
她告诉我的方式就像是，也许这并不是我知道的事情，也许我只需要被告知，然后一切都会好起来的。就像也许这一切都能那么简单。我们回到公寓拿上了泳衣。亚利桑那想去海边。
Arizona treated me like I had never been to a beach before. "This is sand," she said, "and people like to dig in it. Beside the sand is the water, but it's not the drinking kind." She treated me like she was nursing me back to health.
亚利桑那对待我就像我从来没去过海边一样。她说，这是沙子，人们喜欢在里面挖。沙子旁边是水，但那不是能喝的那种。她对待我就像在照顾我康复一样。
For my part, I tried my best to live up to what a six-year-old's vision of fun would be. I bought every single thing the vendors had to offer. I even got us these overcooked, mushy corn cobs on a stick that were smothered in butter and mayonnaise. Mayonnaise. And when she went into the water past her knees, I bit my fist and kept my panic to myself. At the end of the day, Arizona persuaded me to buy a watermelon that some men were selling off the back of a truck.
就我而言，我尽了最大努力去达到一个六岁孩子心目中的快乐视觉。我买了摊贩们提供的每一件东西。我甚至给我们买了那些涂满了黄油和蛋黄酱、烤得过熟、软绵绵的玉米棒。蛋黄酱。当她走进水里超过膝盖时，我咬住拳头，把惊慌埋在心里。那天结束时，亚利桑那说服我买了一个卡车后斗里的人卖的西瓜。
As we rode the bus back home, tired, looking out the windows in silence, Arizona suddenly turned to me and said, "Why did I ever marry you?" I sat there, completely tongue-tied on so many levels. "Tell me why," she demanded, over and over, getting louder and louder, until the six or seven people on the bus turned to hear how I was going to defend myself. "Why did I ever marry you?" All the way home, the question just sat there, big and awkward, like the watermelon on my lap that we would have for dessert that night.
当我们乘公共汽车回家时，疲惫不堪，默默地看着窗外，亚利桑那突然转向我说，我为什么嫁给你了？我坐在那里，在各个层面上都完全语塞。她一遍又一遍地要求道，告诉我为什么，声音越来越大，直到车上的六七个人都转过头来想听听我打算如何为自己辩护。我为什么嫁给你了？一路上，这个问题就悬在那里，又大又尴尬，就像我膝盖上那个我们那天晚上当甜点吃的西瓜一样。
Around that time, Johnny and Arizona invented this game where they pretend to be two old-time vaudeville partners who can't get along. She is always the wiser, burnt-out one. And he is always the mincing boot lick who wants to please the producers and the audience. They pretend they're backstage, yelling at each other, as the audience hollers for them to come out.
那段时间，约翰尼和亚利桑那发明了一个游戏，他们假装是两个合不来的老派杂耍搭档。她总是那个更睿智、更疲惫的人。而他总是那个想讨好制片人和观众的卑微拍马屁的人。他们假装在后台，互相叫喊，而观众呼喊着让他们出去。
"Let's get out there," Johnny yells. "They're waiting for us. They paid a lot of money for those seats. We'll be sued, damn it. We'll be finished in this town." "This is my last show," Arizona says every time, shaking her weary head, "and then I'm through. I can't do this anymore."
约翰尼喊道，咱们出去吧。他们正在等我们。他们为那些座位付了很多钱。该死的，我们会被起诉的。我们在这个镇上就完了。亚利桑那每次都摇着疲惫的头说，这是我最后一场演出，然后我就不干了。我再也做不到这一点了。
They come out into the hallway nervously. They stand in front of the record player, Arizona on top of a Webster's dictionary, to be taller. Johnny starts singing "A Bicycle Built for Two." And Arizona is supposed to be the bicycle bell and sing "Ding, ding." But she doesn't.
他们紧张地走进走廊。他们站在唱片机前，亚利桑那站在韦氏词典上，为了显得高一点。约翰尼开始唱《双人自行车》。而亚利桑那本应是自行车铃声并唱“叮，叮”。但她没有。
Johnny starts the song over again. Still Arizona ignores her cue, staring blankly ahead in the throes of a showbiz meltdown. The audience starts throwing tomatoes, and Arizona ducks behind Johnny. He holds out his arms to protect her from the crowd. She crouches in back of him, laughing her head off, as the angry mob covers him from head to toe in imaginary rotten fruit.
约翰尼重新开始唱这首歌。亚利桑那依然无视她的提示，在演艺崩溃的痛苦中茫然地盯着前方。观众开始扔西红柿，亚利桑那躲在约翰尼身后。他张开双臂保护她免受人群的伤害。她蹲在他身后，笑得前仰后合，而愤怒的暴徒用虚拟的烂水果把他从头到脚覆盖住。
Heather O'Neill is the author of Two Eyes Are You Sleeping, a book of poetry. Jonathan Goldstein is one of the producers of our program, and the author of the funny and surprising novel Lenny Bruce is Dead.
希瑟·奥尼尔是诗集《两眼入睡》的作者。乔纳森·戈德斯坦是我们节目的制片人之一，也是滑稽而令人惊叹的小说《列宁·布鲁斯已死》的作者。
Well, our program was produced today by Jonathan Goldstein and myself with Alex Blumberg, Wendy Dorr, and Starlee Kine. Senior producer Julie Snyder. Elizabeth Meister runs our website. Production help from Todd Bachmann and Maria Schell.
嗯，我们的节目今天由乔纳森·戈德斯坦和我自己与亚历克斯·布伦伯格、温迪·多尔和斯塔莉·凯恩共同制作。资深制片人朱莉·斯奈德。伊丽莎白·迈斯特负责我们的网站。托德·巴赫曼和玛丽亚·谢尔提供制作帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGMENTS]
[鸣谢]
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who describes what it was like the first few years hearing us talk about him like we do at the end of our program.
WBEZ管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责，他描述了最初几年听到我们像在节目最后那样谈论他时是什么感觉。
I think one way to characterize it would be, just to show how tough it was, it was-- [SCREAMING]
我认为表述它的一种方式是，为了说明它有多艰难，那是——[尖叫声]
Torey [UNINTELLIGIBLE]. I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
托里[未听清]。我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。